only an act of true love can thaw a
frozen heart
[Music]
guys we need to talk about frozen -
there are many heartbreaking things on
the horizon for this new film and we
can't keep it to ourselves
grab your emotional support animal and
get ready here are ten things that will
sadly happen in frozen - don't say we
didn't warn you
the tale of two sisters the first frozen
movie taught us that the power of a
sister's love is stronger than almost
anything but what if their bond isn't
strong enough to withstand the events to
come in frozen - in the latest trailer
on a declares I won't let anything
happen to her immediately after that
Elsa is alone in the woods hiding from
some sort of rock beast there's also the
moments in the latest trailer when
Christoph swoops on up onto his horse
and gallops away if you look closely
you'll see Elsa kneeling down in the
background there are clear signs that
Elsa and Anna are going to be separated
possibly for good with great powers
comes great responsibility the frozen
two trailers have shown that Elsa's
powers are stronger than ever she is
using them to conquer the see in the
trailer grand pabbie say that they have
always fear that Elsa's powers were too
much for this world now they must hope
that they are enough but if Elsa really
unleashes her powers will she be able to
control them just look at what she did
to Anna in the first film Elsa is doing
amazing things with her powers in the
trailer and on his hair is showing no
signs of whites so that's a good thing
right but what if there is another
casualty of Elsa's powers that would
truly be devastating honest hours many
fans have been speculating that Anna
will discover her own powers in frozen -
it took Elsa a lifetime and a lot of
isolation to be able to control her
powers surely honorable need time to
learn to control her powers - but what
if she does too much damage before she
gets her powers under control in the
trailers a wild pink fire jumps from
tree to tree it surrounds Elsa in a
heart-shaped inferno else is trying
desperately to put out the flames
she's struggling to do so if anna has
fire powers it will be so sad to see the
destruction if she can't control herself
and will Elsa get hurt as a result who
is the villain in the trailer Elsa is
hiding behind a tree from that scary
rock giant but maybe that's not the real
villain of the story the magic water
horse has also been known to lure men in
their demise in the water but we think
that the horse is else's Ally water
enemy so who is the real villain Hans we
haven't seen Honda many of the new
trailers for frozen - all we know is
that on a punch droid Simpson back to
the southern islets that's the last
we've heard of him so what if he is back
in frozen - Anna Elsa Kristoff Sven and
Olaf are far away from arendelle on a
quest through the enchanted lands that
leaves arendelle vulnerable to an attack
Hans would be eager to find a way to
conquer arendelle while the Queen is
away he would try to take it by force or
worse destroy it to get his revenge that
would be heartbreaking to Anna and Elsa
as well as the subjects of arendelle a
global disaster sometimes think that
Elsa trying to cross that raging sea in
the trailer is a sign of a global
catastrophe
one fan thinks that Elsa will
single-handedly take on global climate
change in the new movie another fan
thinks that frozen 2 will actually be a
climate change thriller that wakes up
America so is it just a storm in the
trailer or something much bigger climate
change seems like a pretty heavy topic
for a kids movie fairy tale survivors
from the trailers doesn't it seem like
Anna and Elsa are trapped on some sort
of island and just when we thought
things couldn't get any worse it looks
like they are trapped on two separate
islands that would explain the
determination on else's face when she
runs at the sea to try and cross it with
her ice powers and on a straight-up
jumps off a cliff to get to Elsa we have
so many questions will they both get off
their respective islands what if only
one of them makes it to freedom Elsa and
Anna's parents in the trailer we catch a
glimpse of Elsa and Anna's mom staring
out the window at the Northern Lights we
know that their ship was racked in the
first movie leaving these young ladies
to fend for themselves well we find out
more about what happened to their
parents in the second movies for
instance why would they leave their
vulnerable daughters alone in the first
place it must have been an emergency
maybe they were trying to stop the Thera
that arendelle is facing now tears will
definitely be shed when we find out the
truth about Elsa and Donna's parents
true love many fans were hoping that
Elsa falls in love in the second movie
they've gone as far as to petition
Disney with a give Elsa a girlfriend
campaign frozen to co-director jennifer
lee said that she loved everything that
people are saying about the film
she said it means the world to them that
they are a part of these conversations
that it is just big enough to make us
believe that Elsa is not going to find
her true love in the upcoming film and
that is so sad Elsa deserves love too
right Elsa says goodbye by far the
saddest thing in frozen 2 would be of
Elsa decides to stay in the enchanted
lands and never return home to arendelle
in fact it's likely that both sisters
will remain in the Enchanted Forest for
good that's going to be devastating to
the people of arendelle what do you
think will be the biggest tearjerker
moment in frozen to sound off in the
comments if you can't wait for frozen 2
then subscribe to our channel to catch
our latest videos about the upcoming
movie and while you're at it give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things see you later
[Music]